حيث قال الجيش الاوكراني ان دفاعته اسقطت
صباح اليوم 15 صاروخا روسيا من اصل ثمانيه
عشر اطلقت من قاذفات استراتيجيه عن طريق
بحر قزوين من جهته افاد مراسل الجزيره في
اوكرانيا ان العاصمه في شمال وشرق وسط
اوكرانيا تعرضت لهجوم صاروخي واسع ومن
جانبها قالت السلطات الاوكرانيه الى
الدفاعات الجويه المضاده للصواريخ تصدت
الهجوم دون ذكر اي تفاصيل عن الخسائر
هذا وقال قائد المجموعه الشرقيه للقوات
الاوكرانيه الكسندر
ان قوته كبدت القوات الروسيه خسائر فادحه
واثرت عددا من الجنود شرق الالمان على حد
تعبيره وضف سيرسكي خلال زياره تفقديه الى
جبهات القتال في مدينه باخبوط اضاف ان
القوات الاوكرانيه تعمل على منع قوات
الروسيه من السيطره على المدينه رغم
محاولاتها المتواصله لاختراق المواقع
الاوكرانيه